hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com so as many of you were
asking i'm here to make a full video
guys only on jme we're going to analyze
everything that happened this week
especially on friday we have some good
things happening there guys some
negative beta finally taking place so
let's go through everything that
happened and see what can happen next
let's get into it
[Music]
all right guys so i'm gonna start on the
daily time frame gme chart i'm gonna try
to give you here what is the situation
for me we're gonna use once again i'm
building a course guys it's gonna be
amazing it's gonna be a course about
breakouts but actually everything is
going to be included inside and the most
important things to check whenever you
trade breakouts is volume volatility
momentum all right vvm remember that so
here quickly let me start from what
happened in november we had this perfect
fake out guys on the upside all right we
had here a very nice consolidation as
you can see just below the trend line
that was confirming this trendline was
important we have this build up that
gave us energy we closed above we
confirmed and still we went lower all
right so it's the perfect bull trap
there's nothing you can do about that
each time i'm going to see this kind of
signal i will be training it uh it was a
perfect trap all right it happens and
whenever you have these fake outs guys i
told you that before but remember it
because we have this happening as well
on the global market fake out on the
upside then usually you have a breakout
in the opposite direction so here on the
downside so we broke out below 170 180
and then we went lower so we're in this
correction the question is is it
complete or not all right so let's try
to use the tools that we have to see if
this correction might be complete first
we use elliot wave theory we know that
the moves down they develop in three
ways a b c when they are correct if
they're developing five waves they are
not collective anymore and usually we
have a small correction on the upside
and then a continuation on the downside
so for now we have three waves so we
don't want to see five first thing and
we know that we have some ratios that
need to be respected between the a wave
and the c wave so the usual ratio are
the 61.8 so it's 86 so we didn't reach
that level okay first information so
it doesn't mean we need to reach it it
just means we were close all right we're
at 92
so it's not that far so maybe i'm trying
to see if bears are satisfied and if
they are they will let's let it go they
will take profits they will cover the
shots all right so this is what we want
to see so
why not i think bears might have reached
their target so first information second
information we check the volume so we
want to see what do you want to see guys
before a reversal you want to see at the
beginning you're always going to have
strong volumes like this you know on the
move down because bears and full control
and you know people are trading a lot
and this means that the moved amazon is
starting here when we see this huge
volume on the red day it means as well
that we're in the middle of the move
down so we're not ready to revert yet
then here we have those low volumes so
it's very good to see it it doesn't mean
that the move down is gonna
end it just means that whenever we see a
higher volume on the green day it might
be a buying signal so here
the volumes are not very low let's be
honest they're low
but they're not as low as they were here
and we have here this bullish candle
after low volume so it's good but it's
not perfect all right it's good and what
i like is that this candle went lower we
open on with the gap down we dipped
first and then we strongly rebounded
from the bottom to the top guys we're
talking about 18 all right that's a huge
huge rebound so now what did the global
market do guys you know
okay
so you remember what i told you guys
fake out on the upside break out on the
downside i'm calling this breakout on
the global market for uh quite some time
and especially since we are here we have
many signals that were telling us that
the global market will reverse bearish
divergence fake out and then break out
on the downside and since we have the
breakout guys i told you it would happen
and that i don't know if it's gonna
if we are entering a b wave on the
global market or not but what i know is
that we have a very strong negative day
on the nasdaq and spy and jimmy is
positive guys so this is the negative
beta we like to see i showed you guys
yesterday on amc how it was look at
jamie
okay guys so what do we see here we see
that this was the article i posted on
twitter some time ago i did it on amc
but the same thing can be true for uh
jamie it's saying that basically five
times in the past we saw decoration
being negative with the return being
very high so this for example here the
correlation is in blue you can see bam
the blue curve is dropping when the
green curve which is the monthly profit
because the smooth the data is going
higher and right now we're having very
negative monthly return for quite some
time all right we're talking about you
know minus 10 minus 10 minus 15
even more than that minus 10 minus 30
all right so very negative um three
returns and the question for now is
positive okay it's positive but the last
day guys the last day is jamie doing
plus four percent when the spy did minus
two percent all right so this is the
first time we see a negative correlation
which is a negative beta taking place uh
between gme and the global markets so
that's good it's a
bit like a hammock candle a bit like
what we had on amc
so this is the kind of signal that we
want to see now the last thing we
haven't checked is the volatility so
we're going to add the voltage bands
guys
okay
and we can see they are wide all right
they're wide it just means that if we
have a breakout so the level we want to
break out above is 110 okay on the short
term so if we have a breakout we're
probably gonna have some continuation
move on the upside but then we would
need to consolidate at some point all
right so we it just means that we are
not ready to do like a massive move up
in the coming months but i think that
next week is going to be a very bullish
and that we're gonna i hope end this uh
bearish cycle that we've been in
for two months so let's see what's gonna
happen so let's see guys that's it for
today i hope you enjoyed this video and
if you did please don't forget to click
on the sub like and bell button so
you're gonna be the first to know when i
upload anything new and stay close to
show i'll see you guys